how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man talking about a lot of
spider-man since the second trailer
should be coming out within the next
couple of weeks and today and last night
i've been getting a ton of dms a ton of
ads on twitter about this supposed
leaked footage of the second trailer
that has come out now it is actual
leaked footage yes i can confirm that
however it's not quite what you think it
is but i'll explain everything that you
need to know about it in this video and
give you a trailer to update and talk
about some pretty cool tobey mcguire and
andrew garfield news also big thank you
to everybody who has told me that it's
been cool that i've been putting myself
in my videos more i'm on vacation right
now so i don't have all my setup but you
can follow me on tik tok and i'll also
be back at it when i get back home in
about a week and yes i'm still doing the
spider-man action figure giveaway all
you got to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and then subscribe to my other
channel cosmic culture we'll link that
down below
so i obviously can't show the footage
because it's copyrighted and i'll get in
trouble with the studios however i think
a lot of people have seen it going
around on twitter or instagram there's a
couple of different videos out right now
and one of them the one i'll talk about
is where spider-man gets paint thrown on
him now this was originally talked about
online by my buddy tyron on twitter then
i elaborated on the scene a little bit
more when i found out a little bit more
details about what is actually happening
here spider-man gets green paint thrown
on him by a mysterio supporter but
what's not in this scene that's going
around that comes later on is that
spider-man actually flips his suit
inside out and that's how we get the
gold and black suit i reported this on
my website thecosmicwonder.com and on my
tick tock which is just cosmic wonder
official yes i do think the black and
gold suit is going to be getting some
type of an upgrade in the show after all
i believe it's called the integrated
suit but i believe that these upgrades
are going to come after he turns his
suits inside out i've been told this by
three different sources so i have every
reason to believe that it is indeed what
is going to happen now i'm not gonna
spoil the footage or anything else for
anybody watching this video but i do
need to address what this footage
actually is because a lot of people have
dm me or added me asking me well does
this mean that the trailer is coming out
soon because when the first trailer was
leaked ahead of time the real trailer
came out the very next day so since this
trailer has been leaked right now does
that mean that we are getting the other
trailer today or tomorrow or sometime no
and i'll explain why this isn't actual
footage from the second trailer this
footage may be included in the second
trailer however this is footage that was
supposed to be in the first teaser
trailer that got cut out it didn't make
the final cut for the trailer however
there is a version of the first uncut
trailer going around which is where
these scenes are coming from but do not
be misled this is not leaked footage
from the second trailer the second
trailer has not been leaked which means
it's probably not coming out today or
tomorrow or the next day yes there is
new footage but it's not really anything
that we haven't seen or know about
already there's some sandman stuff out
there but we all know sandman is going
to be in the film and yes it is super
exciting of course you all know that i
am super excited about it however i just
don't want people to think that the
trailer is going to be dropping within
the next couple of days hopefully you
guys know that i do my best to keep you
up to date with accurate information and
i just do not believe that that second
trailer is coming anytime soon in fact i
do have a little bit of an update for
y'all today now i don't work for sony i
don't know their marketing plan i don't
know all these techniques that they're
trying to do for spider-man no way home
but i do hear things and now it looks
like other people are hearing the same
thing that i'm hearing i heard that the
trailer was going to come out next week
but then i heard that that might not
actually happen i was told that it might
actually come with ghostbusters
afterlife now with everything i heard
there was still a possibility that we
could get that trailer next week however
according to viewer anon a leaker who
has been extremely accurate with
everything that they've put out they say
the same thing now the trailer will most
likely come with ghostbusters afterlife
which comes out on november 19th here is
the exact tweet okay seriously i know
you want to see more footage but the no
way home teaser broke the 24 hour views
record the film is not out of the public
consciousness you'll get the full
trailer around ghostbusters afterlife
and the movie will still make a f ton of
money i also want to say that it would
have been cool if they said you'll get
your trailer when you fix this dang door
but moving on the second part of the
tweet says this is not insider knowledge
by the way studios get to attach one
trailer to their movies so it plays with
every showing that will almost always be
their next release on the calendar
sony's next release after ghostbusters
is spider-man and sadly this lines up
with other things that people have said
and things that i've heard hopefully it
does come a little bit before that but
it looks like we kind of have some
waiting to do right now but this
actually gets me thinking about toby
maguire and andrew garfield there have
been reports that they are indeed going
to be appearing in the second trailer
now this causes a lot of conflict
between the fandom because some people
want to see them the others don't want
to see them until the actual movie and i
completely understand and i can see both
sides but here is what i think i think
that if they are going to show the other
two in a trailer then they're probably
going to wait until the last minute to
show that trailer if you're gonna reveal
something that big it's probably going
to be right before the movie comes out
and if it is going to be attached to
ghostbusters afterlife that's november
19th that's within a month of the actual
release in theaters so perhaps that is
actually sony's plan to show or tease a
little bit the other two spider-men and
do it right before the film and speaking
of that sony and marvel just did
something with toby and andrew that kind
of leads me to believe that it's in prep
for the upcoming no way home film sony
is giving toby maguire spider-man
trilogy and andrew garfield spider-man
duology brand new 4k blu-ray box sex
next month hmm i wonder why they're
doing this could it be because their
spider-man are about to appear in
another movie and they think people are
going to want to go out and buy the old
original spider-man films i bet that's
what it is also they're doing this on
november 8th so that is a date to
actually keep your eye on that is a
monday morning and although i have not
heard anything specifically about
november 8th besides the releasing of
these new 4k box sets if they are
connected in some way shape or form that
could be a trailer date so right now the
dates we're looking at are around
november 8th and around november 16th
now having said this it doesn't mean
that they can't randomly drop the
trailer tomorrow they 100 could and i
really really hope they do but typically
people do know ahead of time when they
are dropping their trailers i have a few
trailer people myself and so far they've
heard nothing or they've heard that it
is coming with ghostbusters afterlife
but of course if i hear anything i'll be
sure to let you all know but i do think
that it's very very convenient that the
other spider-man andrew garfield and
toby mcguire their trilogy and duology
are getting new box sets i mean the
timing of it can't really be a
coincidence however it is kind of just
me speculating at this point i'll admit
that but a lot of things are happening
some scenes are leaking out despite them
being from the old trailers and i'm not
gonna show them because people can get
fired for these guys not trying to get
anybody fired and i actually hope that
we don't get any leaked footage from the
second trailer because i truly do want
to be surprised especially if they are
going to show toby and andrew in this
trailer i don't want to see that on a
crappy video of a video on another
person's phone i want to see that right
on my computer screen for the very first
time and i want to get freaked out about
it but let me know what you think about
all of this in the comments down below
and what do you think about toby maguire
and andrew garfield's spider-man movies
getting new 4k box sets do you think
that's coincidence or do you think that
sony's kind of planning something here
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
always follow me on twitter instagram
and tick tock and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof